do you think some people avoid social  media because they're more introverted  and they're just anxious i think they  avoid social media because they do not  want people to see who they are i think  if more people started to like  themselves what they're gonna find is  the people that uh  should be around them are going to come  around because it resonates with those  people as well and the people that are  offended by it will fade and if you just  let that natural  filtering process happen you're going to  be in a much better environment because  the people around you like you for you  versus me pretending to be something  acting like something that i'm not and  then i'm surrounded by a bunch of people  that that you know i'm walking on  eggshells and or it doesn't last very  long because i slip up and the real me  says something or does something or  politically or otherwise and now all of  a sudden i'm in a  freaking world of drama